what we're going to try to do is use our
powers of calculus to find this blue
area right over here
and what this blue area is is the area
in between successive loops of the graph
the polar graph r of theta is equal to
three theta sine theta i'm graphing it
in polar coordinates here and just to
make sure we understand what's going on
this first loop gets traced out
when theta goes between zero and pi so
this is 0 is less than or equal to theta
is less than or equal to pi and you can
that makes sense when theta is 0 this
whole thing is 0 but then as theta
increases our r
increases as well but then as theta goes
back to approaching pi remember sine of
pi is zero so then this thing will
approach zero again so that makes sense
but then as we go from pi to two pi you
might expect to see some type of a graph
down here but what you need to realize
is when we go from pi to 2 pi sine of
those thetas are going to be negative
and so what it does is it flips over so
instead of having an r right over here
in the third quadrant when we're a
little bit past theta being a little bit
more than pi since r would be negative
it flips over and then it ends up
right over there and so between
for theta from pi to 2 pi we actually
trace out this second circle right over
here this outer one and it makes sense
that the radius is getting larger
because we have this three theta right
over here so as theta is getting
larger and larger
in magnitude we should say the magnitude
of our r is getting larger it turns out
that the r is
it would have been up here if it was
positive but then it goes negative it
goes out here but it has a larger and
larger magnitude because of this three
theta
so that out of the way let's think about
how we find this area
so in general if you're looking at a
polar curve and if you want to find an
area the general notion is
well you would go from
theta
is equal to let's just call it alpha to
theta is equal to beta so this would be
your bounds on your angle and what you
do and we've shown this we've given you
the intuition for it in previous videos
it would be one half times r of theta
squared
d theta is the general formula for
finding the area inside of a polar curve
what we're trying to do here is find the
area between two successive loops for
this polar curve where theta goes from 0
to 2 pi so how do we do that
well one way to do that we could find
the total area in this larger loop
the total area in the larger loop and
then subtract from that the area in the
smaller loop right over here so how do
we do that and at any point if you get
inspired pause the video it's always
good for you to try to work it through
yourself and just passively watch me
work through it so let's do it together
so let's what's the area of this outer
circle if we can include this right over
here
well that's going to be the integral
remember the outer circle gets traced
out as we go from pi
to 2 pi and it would be one half
times
all of this business squared so 3 theta
sine
of theta
squared
d theta that's the outer circle and then
from that we want to subtract
the area of this inner circle so minus
well what are the bounds there well we
said we trace out that inner circle as
we go from 0 to pi
0 to pi
one half
times
three
theta
sine
of theta squared
d theta
now it turns out that this is these are
not trivial integrals to solve on your
own but we have tools in fact if you're
taking a lot of classes they expect you
to be able to use tools if you're taking
ap calculus bc they would expect you to
be able to use a graphing calculator so
that's what we're going to do right now
in order to calculate this quantity in
order to calculate this area so let me
get out my ti-84 emulator
so there we have it and let's see i want
to be able to i want you to see my
keystrokes so let me see if i can
remember that so the first was the same
thing over again it's just different
bounds so the first time so what you
want to do is you want to go to the math
functions
math and then you see right over here
this is your definite integral function
so i'm just going to scroll down there
it's a definite integral and this ti 84
plus ce i guess writes it in nice
definite integral notation sometimes
you'll just see that fn int open
parentheses and then you write the
expression you say what you're
integrating with respect to and then you
give the bounds but here it's pretty
clear so remember that blue integral
right over there
i want to go from pi so i'll do second
that's the pi button right over here pi
2
[Music]
2 pi
2 second pi
and then i'm going to have
1 divided by 2
times
times
and i'm just going to do it with it with
respect to x it doesn't matter if i do
if i do all of the thetas instead of
thetas i use x's so i'm going to have
and i'm just doing that to make it easy
to type into the calculator so this is
going to be
3
x
sine
of x
and then i'm going to want to square
this entire thing
so sine of x whoops i don't want to go
there
sine of x let's see i have
that doesn't close that parenthesis yet
okay so that closes that parentheses
and so i want to square that so squared
so there you have it and then i want to
do dx
so that's that first blue integral and
then from that i want to subtract
so i'll get my math function again i
could just click nine it does the
integral again and now i'm going to go
from zero to pi of this same thing
and so i'm gonna go from zero
to
2nd pi
and i'm going to try to type in that
same thing i am doing 1 divided by 2
times open parentheses
3
x
sine
of
x
close that
close that so that's that and i'm going
to square it
square it and then i have my dx so then
i do dx and if i typed in everything
correctly i should just be able to press
enter and get the value
and i got
139 point well let's just go around to
the nearest hundred point five three
so this is approximately
139.53
square units